have three options but you can only pick
two two yeah the first option is looks
second is money for this loyalty which
two of the three would you pick
um loyalty and money loyalty might say
you'd throw looks out the window yeah
don't mind yeah so if he's uh just like
really really unattractive you don't
mind him every night because he's got
money and he's loyal to you you won't
never cheat now you won't ever have a
wondering eye no so obviously there's
there's when it comes to looks of men
obviously looks is not the main thing at
this point do you know what I'm saying
like you see a lot of women with ugly
men I've dated some ugly men which you
know what I'm saying and why why yeah do
you know it is I asked myself the same
question every day every day I ask
myself the same question
um yet I've been ugly but
but I've still I've still managed to
use that I don't even know
stop doing that please I'll beg you
now but you said it a lot throughout the
whole show like it's a bit distracting
you know what I'm saying I appreciate it
thank you you know some men are ugly but
they're not there's
still attracted to you girls like ugly
men some girls eating ugly some girls
like yeah some girls are attracted to
ugly you know what I'm saying there's
there's an ugly with a Twist sometimes
you know what I'm saying so I take
loyalty and money
yeah you're gonna you don't you don't
mind being with Shrek five foot five
Shrek Shrek Shrek and Fiona look good
together
what
what do you mean five foot four
obviously no I'm saying like you don't
mind being with Shrek as long as he's
got money and loyalty yeah yes that's
cool respect that that's weird
um can I ask you in the corner what are
the three looks money or loyalty what
are you saying which two are you gonna
pick
um money and looks money looks yeah so
loyalty it's not that I you don't mind
sharing that you know it is I just feel
like it's inevitable it might happen and
I won't even know anyway so
so you're just like well
he might cheat anyway so yeah
I just feel like it might happen and I
wouldn't know so to put so much emphasis
on it and then it happens anywhere and I
still don't know I don't know okay so if
the guy's got if the guy's got look some
money yeah yeah and then like you find
out he cheats you out the door or you're
just gonna be like well I knew he was
going to do it anyway so I might as well
stay and other guys are probably gonna
cheat as well so I might as well stay
what will you do I'd leave I can find
someone else to look some money as well
and find another man and then he'll
probably and then I move on again
probably yeah
is that what you care about for real
though yes that's why when you ask the
typical woman her body count she usually
lies you not care about as well and you
lot know we care about it what if she
takes every box and then the only flaw
is
um the body count that you can't take
every box because one of the boxes not
having
um high body count so when you have a
high body count it says to us men you
make bad decisions because you decided
to give out something that's supposed to
be valuable to multiple men and the more
you give it out the less to us yeah
maybe not to other people to yourself
yeah the less valuable we consider you
to be okay isn't that looking for
Perfection no it's not was looking for a
girl who makes good decisions and
doesn't decide to get run through by
Chad and Tyrone if you come to us with
10 bodies because what I'm trying to
make you understand is what possible
good good does sleeping with 10 men 20
men before you meet your husband do for
your husband
okay it doesn't do good but what if like
each time it was a boyfriend no but once
again it doesn't make a difference to us
you still slept with 10 men
is it the fact that you you know who
they are if it was in a different area
let's say you didn't know the guy she
slept with is it different
guys guys that's a question there and
this and this is the problem right you
guys are still trying to argue with it
you just don't want to understand and
this is and this is the indications of a
woman that's been wonderful high body
count because you just won't understand
me it's not me no no no
no listen anyone that pushes back
because good girls are having me run
through they don't they just say oh yeah
that's cool but women not want them to
be silenced no I want you to speak but
if you haven't got a high body count you
wouldn't be talking you just wanted
nothing there's a thing called Hit dogs
holla you know what I'm saying so yeah
so you're trying to degrade all of them
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no
what I mean by that yeah is that like if
you hit a dog yeah it's gonna bark right
if the dog's not hit it won't bark
that's that's what it basically means I
don't so if if if someone say it it's
something yeah if the shoe fits there
you go it's the same when saying you
look old dogs like guys when you guys
are talking about if the shoe fits when
you guys are talking about broke men
when when you guys are talking about
broke men we don't I don't get triggered
at all all these times when you talk
about men paying for stuff I don't get
triggered because I'm not broke I get
money so all of these things no but it's
the I'm not bothered by none of these
things that you want I'm kind of
bothered how can I see okay no wait wait
it's fine but it's not to not do the ad
lips so if you let me speak Girls Girls
Girls Girls Girls this is this is not
respectful no no hold on a second no
this is what we talk about this is very
disrespectful
no no you're not sorry because you're
still no you're still interrupting me
that's not sorry you're not learning
anything my bad this is very you're
still talking very disrespectful so I'm
experiencing you now yeah and I can only
and this is me experience you on a
podcast I can only imagine what it is
for a man that's actually in a
relationship with you you're very
unagreeable and you're not listening
you're talking to a man that's a lot
older than you that's trying to put you
on some game and why wouldn't you listen
all you would do is keep talking
you sound hurt who hurt you I'm not hurt
that kind of so so back to what I'm
saying again the only reason you girls
push back when we speak about body
counts it indicates to me you have a
high body count I don't need to know
your body count I don't I just can feel
your energy and this is what we deal
with so when you want to argue about
wise you're arguing with the right to
sleep with as many men as you want you
can do a woman has the right to choose a
woman has the right to wear what she
wants a woman has the right to go where
she wants a woman has autonomy and
sovereignty over her body but along with
those rights I have rights too and I
don't have to accept a woman that goes
around and sleeps around with people and
this is why you girls get mad see it's
called a preference it's called wait
hold on hold on no I'm explaining
something it's called a preference it's
called a standard that's all it's called
so when men speak like this this is our
standard this is our preference sleep
with 10 men sleep with 20 sleep with 100
men but when you meet the final man that
you want we're gonna see what he has to
say for it thank you now go on go and
say what you want to say
well to that yeah yeah because you get
interrupting so I'm saying like if
you've got I have no response to that to
be honest
um
yeah I have nothing to say we can't we
can carry them well I have to reply to
that man no but I have to reply she
cannot
understand
is that is that your response to the
team yeah yeah all right go on bro so
all you got from that whole thing was my
tone of my voice yeah because why are
you so angry I'm not angry no no no no
no no this is so so once again you go so
this is what you guys are doing right
you keep stopping a man when he's
speaking and it becomes quite irritating
men we are direct we don't do what you
girls do we want to explain something we
want to get straight to it but what you
girls do you keep interrupting and keep
trying to stop stop keep adding ad-libs
it's very disrespectful you have common
invited as a guest of someone's show and
you're supposed as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible